Thomas petrol is a popular instructor
and excellent developer. In this course,
he teaches how to build a live streaming flutter
app using a Gora thanks to agora for providing
a grant that made this course possible. Hello,
everyone. My name is Titus Petra, I am a YouTuber,
Google Developer expert for flutter and Dart,
and also developer evangelist at agora. And
this course will be covering a live streaming
application where you can have multiple live
stream feeds from multiple people coming into a
director application, the director has control
of whether they're muted, whether their videos
on and whether they're on the stage at a lobby,
and then for those people that are in the stage,
their video will get transcoded together and sent
out to any streaming platform that you want. I say
this course is an intermediate level course. So if
you're completely new to flutter, I recommend
taking a look at some of the other Free Code
Camp courses. I know they have some great ones for
beginners. And if you're completely new to Gora,
I'll leave a couple of resources in the
description. So you could see how to implement
simple video calling features with it. I will
also be using ver pot for state management.
I'll be explaining a little bit about what state
management is and how we're going to use it here.
But if you want to dive a little bit deeper,
I'll leave some resources in the description
too. And lastly, I'd like to thank Freako camp
for giving me this opportunity. And let's get
into the course who got a little cold in your
head to put on a sweatshirt. But like I said,
this app is a little bit more complicated. So
I wanted to break it down to visually, we're
going to start off with a homescreen. On the home
screen, we're going to have to enter two fields.
One is the name of the room. The other one is your
name. And as me two buttons, because technically,
we're going to have basically two apps within
one app, we're going to have a participant view,
but we're also going to have a director view.
So the first view is going to be the participant
view. Now this view should look like any other
normal video call you can have, you'll have an
End Call button, a mute button, and a switch
camera button. Within the participant view,
you're basically saying you're going to be a
participant within the video call that a director
controls. So what you should see is basically
what's going to be going out to the public,
the people that are going to be going out to
the livestream platforms, they're going to be
the people that are on the stage, splitting the
stage in this next part. So this is the basics
of the director layout. So the director basically
controls how the whole video calls going, and who
actually gets pushed out to the live stream and
who doesn't. So you'll have first the lobby here.
So when you first join as a participant, you'll
be put into the lobby, then the director will have
the ability to bring you into the stage. And then
you will be basically live. And the director will
also have the ability to bring you back to the
lobby if you misbehave, or something like that.
At the top here, we'll put basically what
streaming platforms you want to go to. So
let's see YouTube and Twitch. If you haven't
heard that, at the bottom, we'll have a menu
for stuff like End call and start and stop
live stream. So as you can see, there's a lot
of stuff going on in this director application.
That's where state management comes in. Not to be
perfectly clear, you don't need state management
here, you could definitely make this app work
without it. But in my opinion, adding some sort
of state management solution kind of cleans up
the code a little bit and makes it easier to
work with. So what is state management. So if
we take a look at this application, within the
director part of it, we have a lot of different
states. So we have stuff like who are the
people on the stage, people in the lobby,
what platforms we're streaming to whether the live
stream is live or not, and things like that. So
depending on how big your application is, and how
much of the state objects you're gonna be using on
different pages, you might want to split it up
into multiple state objects. So you could have
something like a state object for the people on
the stage, a state object for people in the lobby,
state object for what type of platforms you
want to go to, and a state object for whether
the stream is started or not. But for this,
we're going to keep things simple, we're just
going to have one state object for everything
director related. So something like director,
state. Now within here, we'll have active users
lobby users is live variable to tell us if we're
live or not. And which destinations we want
to stream to. So that is the state that we're
going to be managing for this application and
the whole director page. So this whole page
will be reactive to whenever this state changes.
So anytime you update this, the our director
screen will react and update the UI to match
whatever needs to match. And of course, when you
click buttons, so let's say there's a plus button
to add a destination here. Whenever we click, it
will go to a function that changes and updates
this destination, which updates the state which
updates the screen. And thus, we have a nice
simple flow for how things get updated within
our application. Hopefully that makes sense. And
for the participant app, since it's simple enough,
there's not too many things to manage. We're not
even going to use any state management for that.
So how do we choose the gore for this project?
Well, first I worked there, so I'm a little bit
biased. But also it makes building something like
this a little bit easier than other competitors,
and also has a very powerful backend. So you
know, you'll be getting quality and reliability
and all that stuff. Now that your platform will
be taken care of all the video feeds are coming in
and putting them together sending them out to
live streams, but also using signaling between
the director and all the participants, whether
they're muted or whether they should be in the
lobby or the stage and stuff like that.
Alright, enough explaining things. Let's
show how this is actually built. So we're gonna
start off with the old flutter create command.
And we're gonna call this app streamer.
Demo. Okay, jump into the directory
and open it in VS code. And here we have our basic
flutter app. And there we go, we're running the
basic flutter demo application. And before moving
forward want to add in all the dependencies that
we need. So he said, the main thing is going to
be running on his agora, we go to the package
manager for Dart, we type in agora, we will see
three agora plugins. Now we're going to be using
the gore RPC engine and the Agora RTM. But I
want to show you what a gore UI kit does, too,
because it's really quick and simple. So we have
added a gore UI kit here. So this is used if you
want to set up a simple video call application.
Now the plan is to expand this to allow all the
complex features to So technically, what we'll be
building here should also be possible with UI kit
in the future as well. So that's why I want to
show it to you a little bit. So in order to add
UI kit to your project, you only really need to
add three lines of code, we need to create an
agora client, I need to pass in a gore connection
data and enabled permissions. So we're gonna need
two permissions for a video call, we're gonna
need a camera permission, and a microphone
permission. Now that said, your connection data
is a class that we need to add. And you'll see
you'll need app ID and challenging. So what
the heck is that? Well, if you go to console
dot agora, that IO, you'll see a screen like this,
now that have a list of all your projects, you
can create a new project. But for us, we're just
going to be using this project that already have.
But you should see something very similar.
Only creator, you might see a screen like this.
And you'll have a thing called App ID right here.
So this is basically creating an a gore app for
you. And you'll be able to use your services and
you'll have 10,000 free minutes of the services
every single month. So we're going to be copying
this app ID and bringing it into our code. North
not be showing you my app ID this whole time,
I'm gonna have a new file, and I'm gonna call it
app ID. And here on define const, app ID equals
and then insert hap ID here. Name this file with
lowercase and underscores, that's fine. But then
you're going to want to insert your app ID here,
but I'm going to put in my number. So there we go.
Mine's in there. And we can type in app ID here.
And it will import our app ID file. And we can
use that constant variable here. For our channel,
we're just going to call it test for now that we
want to initialize that client. And then we're
done. So all the Gore said is this initialized,
and we will just want to display a stack of
widgets. One of them is going to be the gore video
viewer, which will show you the actual video,
you pass in the client. And then we have a Gora
video buttons. So we could have an called button
and stuff like that. And that's a full video call
application. Before I can demonstrate though there
are some permissions we need to add. So on the
Android level build gradle, we need to add that at
the end of the repositories. So we can add that
in here. Then Add a Device Permissions, which
we already did Android manifest file, add this
required device permission to the file. So there
we go. Now this video call should be working. And
we should be able to launch it and showcase it.
Alright, there was apparently a bug that took a
little while to figure out but there was either
a new Android version or new permissions handler
version that was released. So you want to make
sure you say your target SDK version and your
compile SDK version, both to be 31 by default,
and flutter projects as 30. And something
doesn't like that with permission. So with 31,
everything works. And you just see an app like
this will ask for your permissions. Let's give it
permissions to do all that. And this little image
is something we'll see throughout the video and
is the little fake camera emulator from Android.
Let me join another device just to prove to you
that this works. And I forgot since mine is an
iOS device, we're going to have to add these two
things to the info dot P list file. So iOS runner
info dot P list and add these two keys in here.
Now save that. This time, hopefully it will
work. And there we go. Here I am. So that was
the core UI kit. And while you can do a lot of
things with the core UI kit, you can actually
do a lot of customizations. There's a couple
small things you can't do right now that we're
working on adding in. So we're going to need
to use a core API called a gore RTC engine.
So the core RTC engine handles all
the video and audio related stuff.
But then you also need to add a gore RTM, which
is real time messaging. RTC stands for real time
communication. RTM stands for real time messaging.
And you can imagine the messaging is to send
signals between the peoples so we
can have control of everybody within
the call. So those are going to be the
packages driving the core a core logic.
Then we're going to need the advert pod. We're
going to use flutter River pod, that's for the
state management. And then we're going to
add a couple little small things like shared
preferences, we're going to need this
because we're going to have to have a
UID of a person that we're going to generate
randomly, and we're going to store it. So we don't
have to create a new one every single session.
There's other ways to get you IDs, for example,
from Firebase, nah, stuff, but we're gonna do a
simple route and a shared preferences just makes
it easier for you to store things locally. And
then we're gonna have a couple neat little UI
packages, one's going to
be called App, pop up menu,
just like it sounds, it's just a little pop up
menu, they're gonna have a modal bottom sheet,
which is a nice little thing that comes up from
the bottom, so you can add some information
in there. And then last one, circular menu. So
really, there's three main ones driving the actual
logic behind everything that happens, then shared
preferences just to store things locally, easily.
And then three UI packages, its UI elements that
we could definitely make ourselves bow, why not
use the things we have out there. Alright, so
everything is set up and ready to go. Now I have a
way that I organize projects, it's similar to the
MEU architecture approach. And it's a nice way to
keep things organized within your app, so that
you can keep building up and building up on it.
So I have a folder called controllers, that's not
a folder, I have a folder called models, pages
utils. And sometimes they even have a folder for
widgets. But in this case, we're not going to need
them. So the app ID goes within the utils. We
don't need to look at that anymore. So utils,
as you could see is utilities, stuff they use
throughout the app. But it's not really a feature
or anything like that. So for example, I put
my colors in here, different colors that I have
for the app. And I can't even think of many other
examples of things I put in here. But it's nice to
keep those organized. Then pages like it sounds is
a different pages of the application. Models are
the data objects. So the different types of data
that you hold within the application. And then
controllers are the main things that drive the
whole application. So if you remember how we're
using river pot for state management, and then
we have that director state that we talked about,
so that director state is going to be within the
controller. So you can actually add the file so
we can envision it even better. So we will have
a director, controller. And here we'll have the
director model, which is the big object that
we're going to be using to control the whole
application, then we will have a simple stream
dot Dart, this is going to have the information
for where we're streaming to, and a user dot Dart
for all the people that are going to be within
the call and any data that we need to hold for
them. Then pages, there's only three pages here,
we will have the homepage, we'll have the director
page, and then we'll have the participant page.
Okay, so everything is set up, we're ready to
start adding some code in here. So we can remove
this homepage class, remove all this. And we'll
just call it home, we can leave all that as is
remove the title, we don't really need that. Now,
since we're using river pirate want to wrap this
whole material app with a provider scope. So there
we go. This provider scope basically a widget that
stores state, we're storing state for the whole
application, so wrapping it around this whole
material app. Now this homeless, we have
a problem. But we'll add a stateful widget
here called home. Now we can import that. And I
think we can even make it custom. There we go.
So we're pretty much done with this whole main
page, we won't be touching it much more. Now the
home screen, if we take a look at our design, we
want the home screen to look something like this.
Whether you're a participant or director,
it's actually going to be a little bit
different. Because one, we're going to need
a username. And then we also need a channel
name. So instead of adding channel name here,
we're just going to put it in the first screen.
So in the channel name, username and then two
buttons. So first, we need to create a scaffold.
And then in the body, we're going to have a
center widget in which we will have a column.
Within this column, let's center everything.
And that children will be two text fields and two
buttons. So the first text button will take us
to participant. And the second text button will
take us to director. And actually let's go and
set both of those up. So for the child of the
participant, we're going to have a row with the
word participant and the little icon icons and be
a live TV because you're going to be pretty much
joining a live broadcast. And the child for
the director will be the word director and
a little cut thing so you know you know that
you're directing something or you're in charge
of something. So let's set up our participants
screens as well. So we have a stateful widget
called participant and then in here we will just
do a simple scaffold with a body center Text,
participant. And let's just copy the same thing
to director just to make sure everything works.
By the way, you can click Ctrl, D to do what I
did here. And I just changed all the wording to
director. Now in order to get that next patient
is to navigator dot push and then send our page
route for the specific widget that we want to
push on. So we want to push the participant
widget here. And then do the same thing for the
director, except here, we will push the director
page. Alright, so now we can actually run this
to make sure at least navigation within the app
works. Alright, we ran into a
little bug that then let us run.
So in this Mavenlink, I had WWW dot
jetpack to IO, if you have this,
or I accidentally led you to have this make sure
you remove that. And then your coaching run.
So we have an app that looks like this. And
I think if we click into it will be taken to
the director screen. And if we click participant
will be taken to the participant screen. So our
whole flow for the application is working. Now we
just need to make this look a little bit nicer.
So let's create another folder in here we'll call
it assets, this assets folder, we will put all our
images and things like that. So let's put it out
into the main directory. And there's the assets.
In here we'll have the strimmer, you can't
really see because it's a black background.
But you just got to trust me that
this is the this is the right logo,
not to actually to actually add it into our
app, we have to go to the postback diamo.
And here they have a commented out section that
shows you how to add assets, but we're just gonna
add ours in, and it's in the directory called
assets. So now it's ready to use. So at the very
top, we'll have image dot asset. And our path
is assets slash streamer dot png, that a little
space between this and the next section, we'll
give it a height of only five as some text like
multi streaming with friends. And these can be
constants, because they were not going to change,
add another size box to give some space in between
the titles and the text fields will have a height
of 40 here. And then for text fields, we'll do
something a little more special. So first things
first, we need some controllers up here. So we'll
have a channel name controller and a user name
controller. To format this to look a little
nicer, we're going to wrap it in a container,
I'm going to give it a specific width of media
query width. So this is the width of our screen,
and we're going to multiply it by point eight,
five. So it's going to take up 85% of the screen.
This will make it more responsive for the
different apps that we have. Now within a
text field, we'll have a controller this will
be the username. And then some decoration.
And this decoration is just going
to give it a nice little border
and have the text username in there. So nothing
too special. Now we want to size box again,
of height, eight here, for example. And I'll
hit copy paste the same thing here. And notice a
convert to size box because we're not really using
much else within here. We're not using many of the
container things. So size box works here as well.
And here we will have the channel name and change
this to channel name. Alright, let's run that.
So there we go. It looks looks pretty nice. Now,
now there's one more thing we need to do is we
need to add properties that we pass in here. So
we have a channel name and username, but we need
to actually pass it into these specific widgets.
So there's the participant screen, we're going to
need the channel and the username here. And then
for the director screen, we actually don't even
need the username, we only need the channel name,
but director won't actually be within the call.
So we don't need to see his username anywhere.
But we run into issues here because we're
not passing the specific things we need.
Just simple to fix channel name, we take the
controller we have, and we get the text from
it. Same thing with username, we take the
user controller and take the text from it.
So this is taking the controller that we
have set up for each of the text fields.
So when you're typing, there's a nice little
thing in the background that has all the text for
you and we're retrieving the text value from it.
And then we should have one more problem at the
director where we do something very similar town
name, we take the channel name controller and
retrieve the text. So now each of these screens
should have the correct values that we need,
and we should be good to go. Alright, so for
our next part, we're gonna start implementing
the participants are things the participant is
going to be a lot simpler than indirect or so.
So hopefully it'll be a good transition from
implementing something a little bit simpler.
And then we'll step it up another level.
By adding it into the director, that participant
still has a lot of things that we need to take
care of. And, and since this is a more complicated
app, there's going to be a lot of functions that
the participant has to execute on as well. But,
but we'll take it slow. And hopefully by the end,
you'll have a good understanding of how all these
stuff works together. So the biggest thing we'll
be emphasizing here is how agora RTM and agora RTC
work together. So if you remember, our TM is real
time messaging. So it's signaling is how we'll be
able to communicate information between people.
So send like mute requests and all that type
of stuff. And then I go to RTC will be the
actual video call happening. So on the
participants are things we will need RTC
engine, which is going to be handling the
actual video call. And then for RTM, we will
have a client and then we also have a channel. So
within the core RTC engine or Gore RTC package,
this client and channel logic is within this RTC
engine thing just made a little simpler to use. So
you could add video call a little bit easier. So
the gore RTM, everything's broken down to exactly
how things work behind the scenes. So as I said,
the gore RTC engine will be the actual video call,
they'll go RTM client is you logging into a gore
RTM itself. And then a gore RTM channel is joining
that channel. Actually, let's go and initialize
this, and you'll see exactly what I mean. So here
we're creating the actual engine. And then if we
go to join channel, you'll see you have to give a
token, which will give as No. But then we need to
pass in a channel name. So this channel that you
pass in here does the actual initialisation very
similar to how a RTM does this initialization for
this channel. We're actually not going to be doing
this yet, but I just wanted to show it to you.
So we created the instance of our engine.
Now let's do same thing with our client.
And for both of these, you notice we pass in our
app ID that we created for gore. So now we have a
connection with the engine and the client to our
agora project. So by default, a core RTC starts
with only audio, so we want to make sure we enable
video so we could actually see the video streams,
and then set this person's channel profile
to live broadcasting. There's three types
of channel profiles, there's live broadcasting,
a normal video call, and a gaming one. So we're
going to be using a live broadcasting. And you
can either be a broadcaster or an audience member,
they will be a broadcaster in this case.
Alright, so the basics are initialized,
and we're ready to move forward with it. The
next thing we want to set is our event handlers.
So these event handlers get triggered
whenever some sort of event happens within our
application. And there's a lot of them, we're
going to be implementing a lot more of them.
But for now, let's just do one to showcase how
it works. So we have joined channel success,
you can hover over this, and our occurs when
the local user joins the specified channel.
So we'll do here will actually have a list of
integers with the users that are within this call.
Now, whenever this person joins, we'll have users
that add I'll add their UID to this list of users.
I actually want to set state so we can
update the UI with this specific user shown.
This logic isn't Howard's gonna end with
because we're we don't want to just display the
current user that Johnny wants to display any of
the active people within the stage of the director
application. But we'll handle that a little bit
later. So okay, here we set up the callbacks
for the RTC engine. Now if you remember, we
have an RTC engine, and then we have our TM
client and our TM channel. So those have
callbacks as well. So the RTM client is
your connection to the actual Gore RTM thing. So
there's like a personal connection to the Agora
system. And our team channel is the
channel that you join. So this is like
everybody in the channel will be on the same
channel. But you will be the only one on that
specific client. Hello, editor, Titus here.
So I messed up my wording a little bit there.
He won't be the only one on the client, but you
will have an individual connection to the client.
So this client has callbacks, like on message
received. And this callback has a message and
appear ID so we go to the definition of this. So
this callback occurs when the local users receives
a peer to peer message. So when you get a specific
message from a separate user to you directly, this
callback will execute and we'll just print out
private message from this user with the message of
this. So I don't think we'll actually be needing
to use this call But I thought we would include
it because I think it helps you understand what a
client and what a channel is. But there's one that
we will definitely be using as on connection state
changed. So this one will give us two variables
will give us the current state. And the reason. So
the reason is why this connection state changed,
and the state gives you what's the current state.
And you notice these are integers. And we're gonna
figure out what those integers mean, by going to
developers on a gourd the IO go to documentation,
and documentation, go to API reference. And
we're working with the real time messaging.
And currently, there's no documentation
for the flutter SDK for this. But for now,
I don't know it's coming soon. But it has
the same exact things as the Android SDK.
So we can get status and error codes and go to
connection state. And then there's connection
change reasons. So connection state, we have
connection state aborted is equal to five.
So if our state is equal to five, which
means this connection state was aborted,
you want to leave the channel, want to log
out the client. And we also want to destroy
the client. We could even add apprenticing logged
out. So whenever our connection state is aborted,
we want to just basically clear out everything
that we had going on. Now we can even go to
connection change reasons, we'll get see these
numbers and elegant figure out if you want to do
something specific for whatever reason occurred,
we can do that. But we're just going to keep it
simple for this example. Okay, so those were the
callbacks for the RTM client. Now the last one
is a callbacks for the RTM channel. So these
are channel one messages. This is what we're
actually going to be using to mute people
and all that stuff, because we want to send
a message to every art everybody in the channel,
and then the person within that channel checks
if they're supposed to mute themselves. And then
they will go ahead and mute if their UID is passed
to this channel message. So first, we're going
to use a simple example of member joins. So you
can see these printouts happen whenever someone
joins a channel, that's also have one for member
left just so we can have all this information.
And the last and most important one will be
will be called on message received, where we'll
get a message from the channel and they'll
tell us which member actually sent this channel
message. So you notice these callbacks are named
exactly the same. So we have on message received
here, and our message seed here. But remember,
this is for the client, which means you're
sending a specific private message. And this
is a channel wide message. So this is like a
public message to everybody within the channel.
And again, the documentation it says
occurs when receiving a channel message.
We're going to implement this later. But for
now, we can add another print statement here,
that just tells us the public message. Alright,
so there we go. I know this might seem a little
complicated. But once you actually understand
what's going on here, hopefully it's not too bad.
So the last thing we have the callbacks
declared, We have everything initialized,
there's only one thing left to do on essentially
join all these channels. So first things first,
we actually need to login with the client to
agora. And here's where we run into the next
problem. So we need to give a user ID to this
client. Now there is a way around this where
you don't have to use a user ID. But for this
application, we actually need to because we're
going to be using RTC and RTM. And they need to
have matching user IDs. Technically, the user
IDs don't have to match. But you have to be able
to connect an RTM ID and an RTC ID. Since we're
going to be using these UID to control all the
users, we need to figure out a method to create
these IDs. And to do that, we're actually going
to pass in a UID as well here. And then down here,
we could do widget that UID. And it actually needs
to be a string. But we pass in as an integer for a
specific reason that you'll see real soon. So then
we create our channel. And you remember, we passed
in at the top the channel name from that text
field, we got do that by client create channel,
we get the channel name from the text, we passed
it. But we'll probably notice something here.
We're creating the channel. But we're assigning
callbacks on the channel here. That doesn't
really make sense. So we want to move this
above the channel callbacks. To be honest,
we could probably move it all the way up here
just keep all the callbacks together. But,
but this works just fine too. So next step
is take that channel and we want to join.
So we have the RTM part completely figured out. We
logged in the client, we created the channel and
we joined the channel. Now for the RTC. We have
a very similar approach. We have the RTC engine,
but all we have to do here is just join
channel. And it does all of this stuff for us.
And actually define the engine as a late variable.
So we don't need a question mark here. By the way,
if I went over that too fast, this late variable
is with flutter 2.0 means we're going to
initialize this before we use it. And we know that
for a fact because we're doing it in a net state.
we're initializing it up here and we will be using
it down here. So we'll For sure be initialized.
Again, here, we're not going to be using
a token, channel name will be the same
channel name, optional info, we'll put no.
And optional UID, we actually need it now.
Because we wanted to have a matching UID to our
RTM client. So that's why we need that UID. Okay,
so the initialization, everything should be done
here. I say UI isn't built yet. But I think that's
the less complicated part. So I wanted to get
this out of the way. Now I know one thing we're
missing is this UID. So let's go back to the
home and figure out a good way to do this.
So we're going to implement the UID
here just to keep things a little
less cluttered. And we're going to do that in a
very simple way. If this is a real application,
I'm not sure if that's the best way to do
it, it probably wants to have some sort of
authentication service like Firebase or
something like that, to give you a UID,
they keep track within a database. But
where's it going to create something simple.
So during the initialization, we're going to get
user UID. And if you remember, we added a package
called Shared Preferences. So this shared
preferences just store something locally.
So the first time we run this will generate
a UID. And then we'll just store it locally,
and reuse that same UID that we stored
locally, for any future video calls
a function called Get User ID. And then we need to
import shared preferences. So this get instance,
loads and parses the preferences
from this app from the disk.
So all we have to do is try to retrieve that local
UID. And we'll have two scenarios, we'll either
retrieve an actual stored UID. So that means we
don't get a no value back. In which case, we will
set our UID right here to the stored
UID. Or we haven't created one yet,
and then we will create it. But this should
only happen once. Now I won't type this whole
algorithm out. But let me explain it. So get the
current date and time in milliseconds since epoch,
how do you pronounce it I don't know. But
it should give this exact time and anytime
further in the future won't be the same number. So
this number is a little too long, we need to have
nine digits for Gore to work. So we take three
digits from the front, which are the numbers least
likely to change, and we set those nine digits to
the UID. Once again, that should only happen once,
and then we should be good. So now we can pass
the UID to this participant. And finally, the
back end of our participant side of things should
be done. Now time to serve the front end. Alright,
so we have the UID. In here. Now, the only
things that was left is actually updating the UI.
Actually, there's a couple more things left, we
have to add some more handlers here. So for this,
we're gonna have to do a little bit of logic here
to send the users the current users information.
And when this person leaves, we want to clear
all the users that we're seeing to then also
on message received, this will be a big part of
the application. So we'll have to implement this.
But for now, let's just focus on the UI, get
this looking right. And then we will be able
to see our video call with just this current user,
we can actually add this lead channel handler in
here. So whenever we click Add, call or leave the
channel, we clear all the users in there too. And
now we can move this to do inside the join channel
success and rename it to add join channel logic.
Alright, now let's move on to the UI. So we're
gonna have a scaffold with a center, and then a
stack of widgets. Two widgets we'll have here is
a broadcast view, and a toolbar. So broadcast,
you will be the actual video feed, we'll see.
And then layering on top of it, we'll have a
little toolbar so we can end the call and things
like that. So for the broadcast view, we'll have
we'll have a child of expanded because we wanted
to fill up the whole screen. And then in here, we
will have a an RTC local view and a surface view
of that local view. But we need to import that
can do that right under the RTC engine. So keep
the remote view in here because we'll need it.
Let's ignore that prefix because I don't know
I think it looks a little bit nicer this we can
of course, follow the recommended library prefix
if you want but we'll keep it like this for now.
So on this tastes are local a gore view and makes
makes a view out of it pretty much. And apparently
we don't even need the container how for the
toolbar, I feel like it's easier just to show
it all to you at the end instead of typing it all
out piece by piece. So we will have four buttons.
You'll see a lot of errors right
now because we haven't implemented
anything else because I wanted to take a
step by step but we'll have four buttons.
Each one of them will do some symbols. So
this one will toggle your mute this one on
the call. This one will disable your video
and then this one will switch your camera.
So each one of them has a function and execute and
some of them will need to hold a state actually.
So for this one, this button, it will look
different depending if you're currently muted
or if you're not muted. Same thing with the video
disabled. So let's add those two states in here
and they We'll start out as false. So you're not
muted in this case and your videos not disabled.
And now to actually implement these
functions. So first we have the on
Toggle mute function. And this one, we will
just set the state of that muted variable
to not be muted. So that just
changed the state locally.
But now we need to change that
state within the actual video call.
So we do engine dot mute local audio stream aways,
and we just set it to the variable whether it's
mute or not. So this will work for both cases,
whether we mute or unmute, we'll have something
very similar for on Toggle video disabled. So this
is for the button that turns everybody off and on.
Sort of mute local audio stream will have mute
local video stream as sort of a muted variable, we
will have the video disabled variable. So almost
exactly the same change the camera is even easier.
You have on switch camera. Here, we just call
the engine and everything will happen magically.
And then finally, the last one is on
call end, where we need to pass in the
the build context. And all we will do here is
navigator that pop the context. So we go back to
the previous screen, they might say that doesn't
really end the call that just jumps you out of the
screen. But we're going to handle that in a pretty
nice way where we will add a Dispose method here.
So here we'll basically clean up this whole video
call and whole RTM connection so that we have a
fresh slate whenever we go back into it. So first
things first, we want to leave the channel for
the video call hash. Before we can do that we can
clear the users that we have. So clear this local
variable of users that we have, that will leave
the video call channel, and we can destroy that
video call engine overall, then this is the
RTM channel, we can leave this channel as well
then log out of the client, this is the RTM client
again, and then destroy the RTM client as well.
So we take care of the local state, we clear it
will leave the channel and destroy the video call.
Then we leave the RTM channel, log out of
the client and destroy the client as well.
And there we go. So that so that's a nice way to
handle all that and call stuff because whenever
you leave, even if you click the back button, it
will all execute this and call logic. So now we
should be actually able to run this project, how
it will just see the participant. And when you
click the participant button, you'll be jumping
in a call with just yourself. And we should be
able to see that person that says we're running it
on Android, the way it works is they have like a
emulator camera, which is just this little
pixelated image that they showed that
pretends like there's a camera there. Well,
we ran into some issues, I tried to debug it a
little bit. So if there's no users there, I put
out so that shows no users on the screen. But
if we try to join, you'll see no users at first,
then the user joins, but it's just a black screen.
And when we leave, we get an exception called. Now
this is because we missed a very important step,
we need another package called permissions
handler. Now at this package, we'll be able to
ask for permissions to the camera and to the
microphone. And you can't really have a video
call without permissions to that. So that was
what we were missing. So we're going to need
two permissions, we need permissions
to the camera. And we need permission
to the microphone. And we need to request
both those. So this is for the participant you
and we need to do the same thing for the
director view. Actually, I'm not sure if
it's necessary for the director. But if you want
to add some functionality where you could bring
the director in as well, then you definitely need
this. So now let's try to run it one more time.
Alright, so username is Titus show name. What
is called tighter skin join as a participant
law to allow while using an app. And we want to
allow while using this app. So we have no users
the beginning. And then we get this little Android
emulator. Beautiful. Now we should be able to mute
this emulator. And you'll see the state changes
here should be able to turn the camera off.
And I think this doesn't work because it is an
emulator. So there's no camera to really turn off.
And we can switch camera because that works.
There's like the back camera of the emulator.
And then we can of course end the call and
they'll jump us back here where everything
gets destroyed. Sorry, that's the basic part of
this application. Hopefully you understood all
because it's only gonna get more complicated from
here. Or actually maybe it's not that much more
complicated. But there's definitely more pieces
being added on to what we already have here. So if
you understood this participant section, this is,
I think, the most complicated part of this whole
course, the rest, we're just gonna be adding on
more stuff and making it all work together nicely.
Okay, so you got the participant mostly handled.
Now it's time to start with the director app.
wherein I come back to the participants.
Once we have the active users and the people,
the stage users all set up so that we can send
them over here and we display a different view.
But now if you remember the director application,
so first, we want to set up this director state.
This is going to be our state
object that the director part
of the application responds to whenever changes.
And here, we're going to have the active users,
lab users and then some other little things. But
let's focus on these active and lab users first.
So this active users is the one thing that we're
going to have to go back to the participant side
of things, because we want to not display just
yourself, but we want to display the active users
within the actual call. So let's set up our state,
we need to first create our director model.
So this is the actual data piece that we will
be tracking. This is this specific state. So this
is what types of data we're going to be tracking.
And we'll have our PI create an instance of this
data and use that instance as our state object for
the application. So we will have a class called
director model, I realized my file naming isn't
the most consistent for these I just have stream.
And this one is Director model. But I think it
just made sense in my mind, because we have a
page director, we don't want to have a model
director and controller director too. So just to
differentiate this a little bit from the director
page. So within the director model, we'll take
a lot of things we had in the participants side
of things. So remember, when needed an RTC
engine, linear a client on either channel,
so we will need those same exact things within our
director. And for now, we're just going to have
three more things in here. And that is a set of
active users, a set of lab users and local user.
So sets are pretty much lists, but you can
only have one occurrence within that list.
So we're going to have a list of active users,
our list of lab users, and then the local user,
which is the director. And here we could add a
constructor. So we start off with an empty set
of both users. And then we will add a copy with
method. So I do this using an extension called
Dark data class generator. And they do Command
period, and you can generate a copy with class.
So this will allow you to change one thing within
the object and still have the object. So let's
say you added a lab user to the active user, you
can copy with the instantiation of this director
model that you have, except add a value to active
user and remove one from here, and then you'll
have a new state object. And before we go forward,
we're actually going to change something up a bit.
So I'm going to create a user class as well.
So this user class will be called a gore user.
type of data will need here is a UID. Whether we
are muted or not. Whether the video is disabled,
then a name for the user and the background
color that isn't too important, but it makes it
look a little bit nicer. And I'll show you later.
Again, we need to create a constructor for this.
Answer. Same way as we did before, we will create
a copy with class. So if the user goes from muted
to unmuted, we can change this one variable and
have an object with the new state. Now go back
to this director model, we can actually change all
these ants to be a Gora users. Now we're ready to
go. One more thing. Let's jump back in here. So we
have this list of users, we actually want it to be
a list of Gaura users. Instead of just adding the
UID, we will add an A Gora user with UID of UID.
So we can keep things consistent throughout
the app. Alright, next thing is setting up
the controller. So this is the workhorse of the
application the behind the scenes state manager
of the app, we'll be using ver pod like I said,
if you're not familiar with VO pod and state
notifiers. Specifically, there's some tutorials in
the description that are recommended take a look.
But a state notifier pretty much holds this state.
You can create functions in there that update it,
that we call those functions through this
director screen. So we call those functions
they update the state that says it's a state
notifier it will notify whoever is listening to
update their current UI or whatever it is they
need to update because the state has changed.
So that's the gist of a state notifier. So to
use a state notifier you need to create a state
notifier provider and we're going to go one step
further and auto dispose it says auto dispose
basically whenever we stop using this provider
it will dispose itself. Now within here we need
to give the type of what our state notifier
is going to be and also what kind of state
We'll be managing. So let's create our state
notifier, we will have a director controller
that extends state notifier. And the state that
we will be managing is called a director model.
Now there's this reader that you will see us
passing in this reader is super important.
So this allows you to read the state of anything
within the provider scope. So any controllers
that you have within the provider scope, and
if you forget what the provider scope is,
it's this thing that we surround the whole
application with. So anything within this has
access to that read, are able to access any other
controller that's within our app pretty much. And
during the first demo, I used another provider
somewhere else, but in this case, we might not
even use it. So in here, we need the type of our
state notifier. So we can just actually copy this,
paste here. And the second thing we need is that
the type of the state we're holding as director
model, then all we need to do here is return this
director, controller, with our reader. All right,
there we go. So our state is all set up. Now,
we won't be doing anything right now with the
state. But just know it's there. And we're
ready to work with it whenever we need to.
But the thing we're going to do now is actually
set up our director screen before any of this.
So to do that, we're going to just take the
scaffold and wrap the whole thing with a consumer
widget. Now, this is consumer, which has a
requirement argument of builder. And we'll
take this scaffold and return it just like that.
So what is this consumer to explain the consumer,
I went to the documentation, you can find all
this through the river pod dot dev website.
And the reading about providers
and there's a consumer over here.
And what they say about consumers is that it can
be used to listen to providers inside a stateful
widget, or to rebuild as few widgets as possible
when the provider updates. So this is the thing
that actually listens to the changes within our
provider, in this case, a state notifier provider,
and updates our UI, to look how we want it to
look based on the current state. So in here,
you will see this watch thing, we will use
this watch to look for the director controller,
dot notifier. So let me type one more
thing out and explain these as well.
So we have the director, Mark model, which
will be our director data. And we will watch
director controller. Okay, so what's
going on here. So when we just watch
our director controller directly, we we get this
director model. So we get the current data within
that provider. When we do director controller
dot notifier, we get the director controller.
So we get this first part. And if you see
if we actually hover over the notifier,
we get the director controller here. So the
structure controller will give us access
to all the functions or need to update our
data. And this data will give us the current
data that we need. So just as a quick
example, we might do director notifier, dot
new user, or something like that. But then we'll
have a text widget that is tracking the director
data, active users element at one muted. So
this is a live example. But pretty much, we
have one thing that will do the actual muting of
a specific user. But then when we get that user,
maybe user one out of the active users, we can
read it state from the director data. Okay,
so now everything's ready to go. And now time
to implement all these features. So we're going
to start off with the initialization
and pretty much them joining the call,
want to initialize this video call and actually
join the call from the director point of view.
Now it won't be showing the director camera or
anything, but we still want him to be within
the call so you can control everybody. So the
two main functions are going to be joint call
and then also leave call. Now that joint call is
going to be a little bit more complicated, but
leave call if we go back to the participant screen
is going to be the same exact way as we did here.
Except this time, we don't need to clear any
users because we're holding the state within this
director controller. You notice we get some errors
here because we don't have a private variable of
engine declared. But remember, we have a state
of director model and the director model has
engine client and channels. So we can do
is we can create a cursor like this and
then just type out state DOT engine and
everything will work but we'll get this because
in this case the engine isn't delete variable.
It's actually something that we're will have to
make nullable due to The way this whole directory
controller setup. So that's how we're going to
leave the call. Now to initialize it, we're going
to break it up a little bit, we're going to have
a function called initialize, which will be a
local function that does all the initialization.
Summary, the two main things is we need an
engine and a client. Same way we did here
want to initialize the Gora, first thing
to do was create the engine in the client.
If you remember, we created the channel a little
bit lower in the whole process. And that's exactly
how we're going to do it here. Actually, to
make it easier on ourselves, we could literally
just copy paste this here. But we're declaring
these here. So we need to set them or TC engine
to that, and then import this as well.
And also import a core RTM client
and import app ID. Now initialize it, but they're
initialized into local variables want to actually
add this to the state. So since this is a state
notifier provider every single time, we want to
update the state, we have to set it with a new
state variable so so we're not amending it, use
a change notifier for that, or a state notifier,
we're setting a completely new thing. Of course,
for this initial time, that obviously makes sense
since we're creating an object for the first time.
But this is a key point to remember about state
notifier and say notifiers providers is that
you're going to have to update the state every
time and reset it to that state variable. And
that's why we implemented that copy with function
here. Because we could take all the previous
things that we don't want to change and copy with
the new values. Okay, so we have initialized,
now need to do this whole middle section. And then
again, we go to the participant side of things,
and we could pretty much copy paste this,
obviously, we're going to need to update
specific parts. But the essence is very similar.
So wherever we see engine, we need to do state DOT
engine, wherever we see client, we do state
DOT client mesh, you get some issues here,
because this is named the same thing, but
we're going to change it to st instead.
And now the last one is the channel, we can
change to state DOT channel. So I'm joined
channel success, we don't need to do anything
here, we're just going to print out director
and the UID. So we can just see if they joined
here, leave channel, we don't really have to do
anything here. And the rest of the event handlers
will handle a little bit later. Sir to log in,
there's no widget necessary. Because we're
actually past the channel name and the UID.
We can just remove that. And actually the one
thing that is definitely hard to catch here
is we're setting the state channel. If you
remember I said I mentioned we reassign that
state variable every single time if you want the
UI to update. So this doesn't really work for us.
What we want to do instead is
state DOT copy with channel
and then pass in this channel that we're waiting
for. So now this will create the channel and we'll
be able to access that state channel whenever we
use it. So now we got all the setup for a Gora,
an RTC and our TM setup. And we can close this
function a little bit until we need to add those
event handlers. And it won't clutter up too
much stuff. Let's close this initialize and,
and we can even close this leave call. So now we
want to test it out and make sure that we get this
director and the UID printed out. So like I said,
we're going to do that in the Init state where
we try to join the channel. And in here, since
we don't really care about the return of that,
we're going to read our director controller that
notifier click the Join call function. And we have
a channel name that is passed into this widget and
we have a UID that's also passed into this widget.
Or so I thought I guess it's not passed
in yet. So we want that to be passed in.
Alright, we've got on the home screen
and then Director screen now as well.
So this context read, if we look at the
description, it reads a provider without
listening to it. So just watch, we're listening
to all the changes and we want to update
depending on what's going on here.
And here. We just read it and
we forget about it. So we would just call that
join call function, let it do the rest and we
don't even have to worry about it. So okay, then I
think the director applications should be working
now. If we run it, we should see our emulator pop
out a director with the UID print out just like
that and then we'll know everything works on this
end. Okay, so we were able to get to this screen,
we see that the store ID is 634657764 and we
joined the director sees something very similar
So username, we'll go with Titus,
Titus here, click director,
we get to the director screen and director
Boom 634657764, the same exact UID
as you got there. So it seems like everything
works, we're able to join the call.
Now we can move on to the next section.
And that's actually bringing on people
into the lobby and into the staging,
managing multiple users within the call.
And we're going to do that by going to the
director controller, and then there's join
call function. So remember, I said, we're going
to add more events to the event handler, we're
going to have an event for user joined, and user
offline. Now in this first section, let's just
print out that the user join. So we can have all
the details in there. And here, we're just going
to have to implement two functions. So we're going
to have add user to lobby, okay, I need their UID.
And then when the user jumps offline, for whatever
reason, we want to remove user. Again, wanting to
define which user we want to remove. Now, let's
close up this joint call function and implement
those two functions. So the first one we're going
to have is the Add User to lobby and remove user.
And we see these errors that we had here go
away, now we just need to implement them.
So these two functions are actually pretty
straightforward, we just need to add a user
into our lobby users set. So let's get
into since since this is a state notifier,
we need to reset that state variable. And we'll do
that with a copy with me to update the lobby users
value. We're going to do that by taking
the old lobby users. And I forget what this
what this is called again. So this is called
a spread operator, you put these three dots
before a list, and you get all the values
within that list added into the previous
list. And same thing works with sets. See, we're
taking all the lab users putting them in a list.
And then at the end, we will add another
lobby user. So be defined as an a gore user.
Eu ID, we're getting that passed in.
We want them to be muted at first.
They want their video to be disabled at first as
well. The name, we don't have that part sorted out
yet. We'll actually instead of naming a weight,
we'll name it to do to dude. And background color.
We also don't have this sorted out, but I'll set
it to blue for now. We'll do that real soon. But
let's implement the remove users. And then also
allow them to be moved into active users as well.
So the Remove user is actually a little bit
more complicated than the Add User to lobby
since we need to check in both the lobby and in
the active user state. But it's still not too bad.
So first, let's create some temporary
sets. And then all we have to do is
loop through all of these people in the
active users list and in the lab users list.
So you see this as a nice for loop that goes the
length of the active users checks if the element
at that user is equal to the UID, which we want
to remove, and if so remove it from that list.
And once we have that update the state with our
new active and new lab users. Now we're going to
switch a little bit to the UI side of things. So
we can actually see this stuff working in action.
But before we do that, we're going to set up the
base of the next two functions that we're going
to need to add. So we had add user to lobby remove
user, but there's two more functions that we need.
And that's to be able to promote the user to
an active user while they're in the lobby. And
to demote that user from an active user back into
the lobby. And I guess before we even go to that,
maybe it makes sense to actually implement these,
they're not that much more complex than these
other functions. So to promote the user, the lab
user to an active user, we want a temporary lobby
of all the current lobby users. And then this temp
color and temp name is this name and color that
we're assigned right here. They're obviously not
initialized, but we want to pass that value on to
the active user as well. So similar loop, we loop
through the temporary lobby, we check when the UID
is equal to the UID that we want to promote,
let's say this temporary color that we have.
So from the cigar user, we're just copying
this these values into a temporary variable
and then removing that person from the temporary
lobby. After remove it, we need to set the state
again. So now the active users will be the
previous active users plus a new agora user
with UID UID. Background Color equal to temp
color and their name will be equal to temp name
Okay, So recapping, we updated the active users
to have the new active user. But remember,
we also update the lab users to use the new
lab users without the specific person in there.
And now we could pretty much
copy paste the same exact thing.
So very similar code for the demotion process. But
wherever we see, lobby, want to change to active.
And then wherever we see active, want to change
that to lobby, the only difference here is we want
to make sure they are muted, and that their video
is disabled. Okay, so even that's added and no,
so the management of all the users going between
the active users and lab users is all complete.
Now let's implement the UI so you can actually
see it in action. So for the UI part, we might go
a little bit faster, just because the UI I think
matters a little bit less the how the actual back
end of it works, I think, is the most important
part of this course. But I still wanted to cover
the UI here. So we have our whole scaffold wrapped
in this consumer widget. So if you remember,
this will keep watching our state for any
changes. And we'll be able to update our
UI whenever any of those change. So inside the
scaffold, we will actually be doing a custom
scroll view. Because we can have a bunch of people
within the call within the lobby within the active
users and want to be able to scroll nicely. And
then this will be implemented using slivers.
So the first section will have
a sliver list. A sliver child
list delegate. And here we'll just add a nice
safe area where for now we're just put the
word director in there. So if you don't know what
Slivers are, Slivers are pretty much little pieces
of code that work well with within a scrollable
view. And so the sliver list is very similar to
just a widget within the sliver. So like a nice
row, within a sliver view, or within a custom
scroll view. So the next part is we're going
to check whether the users are empty or not.
So I take the director data and see if
there's any active users. And if it's empty,
we will just display another sliver list that says
this is an empty stage. But this is where it gets
a little bit more interesting. Here we'll add a
sliver grid. So for the sliver grid, we'll need
a delegate and a grid delegate. So for the grid
delegate, we're going to define something called
a sliver grid delegate with Max cross axis extent.
So this section pretty much defines how big each
of your children are going to be. So here, we
define the maximum extent of the cross axis
for each title, we wanted to take up half of the
screen, I wanted to have some spacing in the two.
And the way we get half the screen as we get as
there needs to get the size object. And we're
just going to define it up here, because we'll
probably use it in a different section as well.
So we define the size by doing media query
context, dot size. And this determines the
size of how many pixels is the size of our screen,
pretty much. So we take the pixels of our screen
divided by two, that's how much each grid element
is going to have. But we also want to have it give
us some spacing of 20 pixels. And that will give
us the look that we want. Then there's a delegate,
which is the actual child. So this defines
what we want each child to look like and how
many children there is going to be. So here we'll
use a sliver child builder delegate. So in here,
I just decided to cut and paste to make a little
bit easier. But let me explain to you. So at this
sliver child builder delegate where we get the
context and an index for which child it is.
So total child is going to be the active users
dot length, so how many active users we have.
And then each child will have the following
design, where we'll have a row, and we expand it,
and then create this stage user. Now the stages
here, I'll just paste it in. And then we'll
set up the rest of it and show you what the UI
looks like and go through this in more detail.
I think it's kind of hard to imagine just with
words, okay, and then we put a little divider in
between. So once again, using a sliver list. And
here, we'll just do a divider with thickness of
three, and then some indents on the side. And then
literally a copy paste of this above thing for
active users, except the same thing for lab users.
Now, again, we need to implement this lab user,
but I'll just copy paste in. It's the same layout
as the staged user. But I think it'll just be
easier to showcase when you could actually see
the UI as well. So I think that's the UI for the
most part I know there's a lot of higher pacing
here but we're going to go through it right now.
After we started up so I could actually
showcase you with an example app and,
and what each part actually does. Okay, so we
have user name. We'll just call it director
says username doesn't really matter channel will
go to Tada. Click director. And we should see
this weird director text at the top. It's there
for a reason right now, you'll see it soon. But
we could have just added an empty container there.
Actually, let's let's do that just to make it
just to make it a little bit less
cluttered. So with an empty container,
it's a little bit less cluttered. And
we have the stage and the lobby here,
now actually need to join from a different
device for the first time. If you remember,
in the director controller, when we said when we
joined, we have a color of blue, and the name has
to do, that's what we get here. This is why we set
the colors. So we're going to let the people input
their colors and have their names appear here. But
for now, it's to do and the color blue. So this is
the design that we have. And there's actually one
piece I missed to make it look a little bit nicer.
Actually, within the scroll view,
let's add some padding around this.
And we could actually keep it at eight. So
now it's going to look a slightly bit nicer.
So back to the lab user, let's see what we did
in order to get this UI. So use a clip, our
rec service takes the rectangle that we created,
we created the blue rectangle and takes off a
little bit of the border. Now in this case, we
actually check if the video is disabled before
showing our stack of widgets, FS not disabled
will actually show their view. And I realized
this probably isn't necessary anymore, because as
a lab user, your video should always be disabled.
So we could simplify this a little
bit. So in this clip the rectangle
we have a container that has the color
of blue that we pass there and with.
So this is the we take the lab user, and at that
element, we take their background color value.
So the background color value is blue. And for
some reason, there's some air with this background
color will display black. And if there is no
name, we display error name, but we take that
lab user at that specific element, and we display
his name. And this one we have to do so I guess
we could have not added to do or color. In this
case, we would just get black and an error name.
And then this is all within the stack. So
on top of it, we have a little container
with again, a border radius
of 10 to fit into the corner.
And that's that's what this is. So it's like
a little button that fits into the corner.
We made it a little transparent
black. And whenever we press on it,
we will promote this user to an active user.
And if we set everything up within the director
controller correctly, or press this button, we
should be taken into the stage. The video should
come in of me. And we should have a very similar
UI on the stage. So let's try it out now. Tada.
So here we go. So for the stage user, we have a
very similar UI, we'll have the same rectangle
that we had here. I said now we actually care
about the surface view that we would have.
And then we want to put buttons on top of that
service view. So we'll have different buttons,
one to either bring the user back into the
lobby like this, or to turn off their video
or to turn off their audio, and the video is
turned off, we'll have a nice video off screen.
Then this section takes that background color that
we have from the user puts at the bottom corner,
and then tastes their name. And as they hear,
as long as you know their names available. I
noticed we have these buttons over here. So I
kind of said some of the functions out because
these aren't implemented yet. But when we click
on these will toggle the other users audio and
the other users video, these buttons have a very
similar setup as what we saw in the lab user,
except there's three of them now. And they also
change colors depending on the state. So when the
video is disabled, this will be red on the video
is enabled, this will be white, and same thing
with the mic muted. So that's what the stage user
widget looks like. So the next step we're going to
do is actually implement these toggle user audio
and toggle user video functions. So these, when
we see the word toggle, that's when we're doing
it as a director, we're toggling them on and off.
But there's one thing to remember is that the
participant user can actually click these toggle
buttons on their own side. And we need to update
these states based on that as well. How to do
that through the event handler where we will find
there some functions to check whether the user has
updated the audio or video, we will be adding
four new functions here. So first one will be
toggle user audio will need to pass in which index
of the user is so in the UI, we actually know
which active user needs to be toggled so we could
just pass the index directly make it a little easy
on us. And then if we want a muted we will send
a message to mute and otherwise want to unmute.
Send a message to unmute. They might be asking why
are we sending a message instead of unmuting them
directly so This mute functionality is actually
going to be a sending a request for the user
to mute themselves. Actually, maybe that made
some more clear to start with the update user
audio then. So this gets a little bit complicated,
because again, we need to rewrite the whole state
object here. So we're going to do is actually
take the whole agor user, we're going to find
the element where the UID equals the UID, we pass
in, we're going to set that to a temp variable,
however, a temporary set of active users, we're
going to remove that specific temporary user,
I'll add that user back in with whatever
mute state that it needs to be added in with,
now we just reset that state or reassign
that state with the new active users.
And that should totally work fine. Now,
there might be a better algorithm to do this,
there might be a simpler way, a more
efficient way. But this works just fine.
Now, let's copy this function. And change
this to update user. video instead.
So same logic, here, we're going to find
that user within the Active Users list,
we're gonna create a temporary set.
But then instead of copying muted
when a copy video disabled, now need to execute
those functions when an event gets triggered.
And the event that we want to get triggered is
remote audio state changed, and for the other
one will be remote. Video state changed. And
here we will check. His state is equal to audio
remote state decoding. And if we take a look
at it, what this means it means remote audio
stream has decoded and plays normally. So that
means we're unmuted and we should be playing.
And then we can actually just call that update
user audio with the UID and muted with false.
Then otherwise, if state is equal to audio remote
state, that stopped, want to update user audio to
be muted, in this case, very similar thing
here. So we need to change this to video.
And change this to video disabled. So you can
actually test this out on our device to see if
it updates to the correct color. Alright,
again, the username doesn't really matter.
Channel name, Thomas will go to director.
Nobody here. I'll join on my end.
Here we have a participant. I'll
bring this person into the stage.
And there we go, I'm muted. And you can
see the red icon. By turn on my camera,
you see video off and camera turns off. I turn
it back on, everything seems to be working well.
Okay, so that section was if the user mute
themselves on there, and so we have it updating
accordingly. Now as last part is we need to,
we need to be in control of them as well.
So we have toggle user audio and toggle
user video, we had toggle user audio,
almost implemented. Yeah. So we need to be
sending a message to mute and unmute them.
And this were our Gore RTM comes in real handy. So
we're going to send them a message, they're going
to mute themselves. And then through this function
that we implemented up here, update user audio,
we will get their updated state here but
they will pretty much be muting themselves.
So we want to do here is take the state and
it's going to be a channel wide message.
So we're going to send a message and the
message is going to be formatted like this.
So yeah, our Chem channel from text that
our Tim channel RTM message from text.
And if we're already muted
that means you want to unmute
and we want to make sure to give
the UID of who we want to unmute.
So our message is going to say unmute
followed by UID. Same thing here
except here we are no muting what
that Id are looking copy paste this
and change this a toggle of user video.
Instead of muted. He will just say a name
If enable, we'll use the word disable this
UID. And then if it's already enabled,
we will enable it. So the next part of this is we
need to accept these messages and do the correct
actions upon these messages. But in order to
not jump around everywhere, let's add all the
other RTM send messages in here. So if you
remember back to this drawing, to participant,
you, you shouldn't be seeing yourself, right, we
need to be seeing all the people within the stage.
So we need to somehow send all the users that are
within the stage to the participant. And that's
going to be the last type of message that we're
going to be sending. So we're going to send audio
mute and unmute messages, we're going to send
video enable and disable messages. And we're going
to send active user messages. So these are going
to meet need to be executed every single time
something changed with the user. So all four of
these functions, we'll need to have some sort of
active user message. I'll actually create another
util here. We'll call it message that Dart. Now
these helpers are going to be used to make it just
slightly easier for us to work with sending all
the list of active users. So we're going to have
a class called message. And it's going to have
a function inside that returns a string, because
our team message needs to be a string. And we're
going to call this son active users. So we
need to be passed in a set of agor users
will need to be turning this set into a string
value. So our string will start with the keyword
active users followed by
space, the space is important,
then we set up a four loop to
go through all the active users.
And let's actually set up our
return to return the user string.
Out in this for loop, we're going to append on to
the user string. So the user string plus active
users dot element at this specific index, we
take their UID turned into a string and then
add a comma after that. So this is where
our messages are going to look like.
It's going to look like active users, which is a
keyword we're looking for, and followed by UID,
UID, UID, UID. Okay, we're going to send
out this string. But when we receive it,
we actually need to parse that specific
string and get that list of users again.
So let's create that function here. So we want
the list of gore users. Parse active users,
I'll pass in a string of UU IDs. So before this
step, we will look for a space within the code
that will tell us that this is active users
and we will send the string of UID UID UID UID.
So this the type of string that
we're going to retrieve here,
so I'll create a list of the strings
and split them where the comma is
out here to be turned into a gore users. So
we can use it within our app. So we'll need to
loop through all the gore users who will check
if this is an empty string, because remember,
we're parsing on every comma. At the end, there
will be an empty string here with nothing.
So I want to get to that point want to continue
out of the for loop and keep keep going. Before
we get to that part, we want to take all the users
and we want to create a gore users from that UID.
And we get that from the list of strings that
we have. We parse it, turn it into an integer
and set it to our UID. And finally, we're ready to
return to users. Right? That was a little bit more
algorithm heavy. Hopefully, this all makes sense.
We're basically working with string manipulations.
Now going back to Director controller,
so so we need to add it to these four
functions. So when we add the user to
lobby, we want to set out send out a
message of these active users so that the
participant can update their own screen.
So we take the channel, send message, or
message is going to be a Gora RTM message.
From Text we're gonna call that message
class we created and say send active users
and active users we're going to send as the
current state of active users because we
already just updated that state right here.
So we updated, the state is new and ready to
send out. Now when we promote them to active user
can copy that same thing. There'll be a new
user. But on top of that, we want to add two
more messages, want to unmute that person, and
we want to actually enable their video as well.
We don't want to have them come into the
stage and their videos off and everything,
that'd be a mess. So now when we're demoting them
to a lobby, we want to do the opposite of this.
Well, except for that last line, we'd
still just want to update with the current
state of the active users. But in this case,
you want to mute that user and want to disable
their video. And lastly, when we remove a user
we'll send them to new active users as well.
And we don't have to worry about muting or
muting them because they're gone. Okay, we're
getting very close to the finish line here.
So next part is we want to retrieve the states
with the participant side of things, I want to
address those actions that are those messages
that are being sent over, we want to listen to
them and do the correct thing. So you remember
these messages, we were sending out our channel
wide messages. So we're going to be using this
section a lot. So this is where we'll see our
message and which member sent it and all that
stuff. So first thing we need is to parse for that
space that we added. If you remember all of
our message definitions, we have that first
identifying word either enable mute, on mute,
disable, or active users, followed by a space.
So we're gonna split that text into a list of
strings based on where the spaces now we're gonna
set up a switch case statement, we can look at the
parsed message and position zero because we know
there should be two positions total, the first
specific word and then the rest of the message.
So in the case that we need to mute, we will
check the parse message and position one
will check if it's equal to our UID. So we
need to set the state of muted to equal true,
since we want to meet this person, and insists
that only does it locally like on our side of
the app, we want to also let the engine know
that this person has muted themselves. Now this
mute local audio stream will trigger our director
controller event for remote audio stay changed.
If it's muted or stopped, this will execute.
And then the rest of the logic executes. And I
can imagine we'll have something very similar for
the other cases. So we'll have the case of unmute.
Where this is just false. And this is false. And
now we'll have the case of disable and enable.
Or this will be video disabled.
And this will be mute video stream.
Last one is actually becomes pretty easy for
us as well, because of how we set up that
parts active users function. So we get active
users as the first part of that parse message.
Let's add a break in here. So we don't forget,
all we have to do is set state and set our current
users to message parse active users. UID is
going to be parsed message at index one. He just
can't be a setter, because it's final, who made a
final, I didn't make a final was supposed to be.
Okay. So all the messages are accounted for. Now
one of the last things we need here is to actually
show the UI of all the users. So toolbar is
pretty much done. The main thing we had to
do is is broadcast you. I think I'll just
copy paste this in here because again, it's
it's not the most important part of this
application that we're dealing with.
And this reminds me we need one more
thing to add in. So this active users
so want to have this variable called active
user to know if they're on the main page or not.
Because we don't want to display all the buttons
we don't want to have them the ability mute or
change their cameras if they're not even on the
screen. And let's actually change this name to
local user active because we Have the active
users over there, I don't want to get confused.
So we'll update this. And I explained that logic
in a little bit, but let me update the buttons
first. So we have the mute button here, want
to check if the local user is active, if he is
active, then we want to display that Material
button. But if he's not just display an empty
size box, then call button we do want because
we wanted them to be able to leave the call.
But the video disabled button we don't want again,
same situation as above, we'll just create
an empty size box. And then switch camera,
we again don't want this. And if it's not active,
then we want to display a sized box again.
Alright, so there, the buttons are updated.
Now let's go through the view a little bit.
So as broadcasts, you gets all the render views
that we have. And the render views function,
we have a list of all the users. So we
have the gourd user with the UU IDs.
We go through that list. If the
list is equal to your own UID,
then you create an RTC local surface view.
So that means it takes your camera view.
And that's what we're going to be using.
And we're going to be putting the user's
username at the bottom as well. And then so if
we already did a check to see whether you are in
the active users list, so if you are
then check if local active gets set.
And that's how we set the local user active thing.
Otherwise, we will use the RTC remote surface
view. So this means a surface view or a video
view that is not coming from your own device.
And then again, same thing will have their
username at the bottom right. So you get these
stacks of different views. And now we need to set
them into a grid of what we want to look like.
So if zero, you take up the whole screen, if it's
two, you take up the top and bottom. And then if
you have three or four, you set them into their
own view, if you want or need to add even more,
you can with a golfer you can add up to 17. And I
think that might be increased soon, even. I mean,
he's expanded views just put this into an expanded
role pretty much. So that's that's the UI,
the core thing you want to understand here is
how the gore logic works here, the UI is I'm not
as worried about alpha or UI key don't even have
to worry about that in the first place. So okay,
let's run it. Let's see if it works. Okay,
so we will first try out the director part
where we'll try to mute the people. So
when we join will see is blue to do again,
on my side, I see only and call button,
but we'll showcase that here as well.
And then we bring the user in here, we should
be able to mute them. So let's try it out.
There it works. And I can actually see our mind,
we'll swap the roles around and then I'll show
you there too. But I can show you here, we
turn off the video, and makes the video off
and everything's working well. Now, let
me show you this from a participant point
of view. So if we join as a participant
received and call button with nothing else.
So this is the lobby, we don't see anybody in the
lobby, but when we try to bring the person in,
you will see we had the name director,
and we have that little Android emulator.
And now I won't see my mouse here, I'll click mute
on the other end. And you see the state updates
here to be muted, and I can turn off the video.
And those still see it here locally, because we
don't update the UI to do anything when our video
is off. And we're still technically on the stage,
we see the status updated. So okay, everything
seems to be working well. So last thing we need
to do is add some logic to generate the color
and send the name of the user to the director.
And we're going to do that within the participants
to join channel success. So this is when you
successfully join the channel on your own. And
I can actually remove this users that add here.
Because we're not relying on this anymore, the
director is sending us all the information for
what users we actually need to display. I actually
saw a little hiccup on my second device when this
first launched, because I saw the screen pop up
for a second and then go back to nothing. Because
we added that user here on this joint channel
success. But then as soon as we received the
message, we set that back to nobody. So that was
a bug that would have totally been hard to spot.
So let's generate a random color and then
also give the name that we want to pass.
So to get a random color. We're just going to
do random dot Next, double multiply by that by
all the colors and turn it into an integer. And
to send these we're going to be using a local
attribute that we can get access to from the
director directly. It's a good way to phrase it,
so on to add or update local user attributes.
This attribute is going to be name and color. So
see these local attributes take in a list of maps.
So we need to create key value pairs for the name
and for the color. So the first one is
the name. And then let's get the color.
Color, the key will be color,
and random color.to string
to string as what we will want to pass
here. So on the director side of things,
if you remember when we first
joined, right here, we just set it to
a to do and colors blue. Instead,
we're going to get the user attributes.
And we do that by asking the client for the user
attributes for this specific UID. And to access
them, we just get the key value pairs, we'll
look for a name. And to set the color, we want to
get the integer, and then user attributes.
Color. Okay, now unless I'm missing
something, we should have colors here.
So there we go, we joined, you'll see we got a
random color, we see the name Thomas, if we leave,
join back, oh, should get another random color,
I believe, a darker green. Hopefully, they're not
all going to be greens. Yeah, we've got a nice
orange here. If we bring them into the call,
we'll see the same orange with the name down here
seems to be working great. Nice. So all the core
logic with the lobby and active users and sending
RTM and RTC messages is all done. We're getting
all the people within the call. And now the only
thing left to do is to actually stream them out to
all the other platforms. And to me, this is the
most exciting part. So if you remember, we had
this model set up called stream, but we never
added anything to here. Let's change that. So
first, we're going to create a Num called stream
platform, we'll add YouTube, Twitch and other
they'll have a class called stream destination.
This will have a string platform
and a URL where we want to stream.
So this is a very simple class, we just
want the platform and then the URL.
So this section even though it might seem like
it should be complicated with a gore, again,
it's not too bad. So let's close all these
functions just to make our code a little bit
more readable. And at the bottom here, we're going
to add a couple more functions. And before that we
need to update our director model to because we're
going to need to store a couple more things here.
So first, we need a Boolean for his life. So know
whether we are currently live streaming or not.
And then we will need a
list of stream destinations.
So that we know where to stream to. And then we
need to update that copy with function. But again,
we need to fault for that. So we're going to start
with false. And our current destination starts
with zero. Alright, so now that we got that data
in there, we can go back to Director controller.
And we could work with that now. So we'll
have data for whether we are live and all the
destinations we want to stream to. So the first
function, we're going to want a start stream,
second function will be called Update
stream. So if the user gets brought to stage
law, the stream is live want to update that
user, we want the ability to end stream,
then a function for publish destination.
And we're going to need to import this enum
as well. So add publish destination is when
we click we want to publish to YouTube,
or Twitch, we will add that into our
destinations. And then if we add it,
we need an ability to remove it. So these are
actually the last functions that we're going
to need within our controller. One thing we
want to do before diving too deep into that
is whenever there's a change with the active users
want to check if it is live, and if so want to
update that stream. So this is the scenario
when you get promoted to an active user.
This is the same scenario when
we demote to the lobby user.
And then also the same thing if we remove the
user. While this isn't always going to be the
case, it doesn't hurt to update the stream just
in case. So now to add publish destinations.
We want to give the ability for people to add a
publish destination while they're already live.
So if you're already streaming on YouTube,
you want to add it into Twitch real quick.
You can do that and it should update.
So here if we check state that is live.
If we're alive we want to take a
state engine Add publish stream URL.
So our past in this URL and transcoding
enabled was set to true. Now I'll give a
little bit more insight on what that
actually means a little bit later.
And then whether it's live or not live, we want
to update the state with the new destination.
We'll do that with copy with then destinations.
And very similar to how it did the users,
we want to use the spread operation, get all the
destinations and add a new stream destination.
Let's platform platform URL URL. So to remove
a published destination, we got to do something
very similar. So check if it's live, if
it is want to remove published stream URL,
we don't need transcoding. And then
we do a little bit of logic here,
where we loop through all the current
destinations, we check if we check for
the location of the current URL that we want to
remove, we remove it, and then we set the state
with the new locations, and we can return we
don't need to loop through the rest of it.
So that's how we add destinations. And that's how
we remove destinations. Now we actually have all
the data we need to finish up the UI, we have the
complete director controller with all the pieces,
we can finish that up. And then the last thing
we're going to need to do is implement these
last three functions, then we can show you the
fully working application. Alright, so for the UI,
we have the little section at the top where we
want to add all our streams and things like that.
And actually, since this is all gonna be UI
stuff, we can just launch this app and see our
changes get updated real time. Actually, before
we get into all that, we want to wrap our custom
scroll view in another widget. And this widget is
actually one of the packages that we installed.
Called circular menu. So let's take our custom
scroll, you wrap it with a widget. We'll call it
circular menu, just like the package wants. So
items is required. That's the required field.
And then instead of child it should be background
widget. So a circular menu puts basically a little
floating menu thing above our whole view. So we
have the items. But we can also add some things
like alignment. Or gonna align it to the bottom
right in change the toggle button color two
colors, black 87. And might as well give
it a little bit of a shadow just to give it
a little extra spice. Now for your login
to this director channel, we should see an
error pop up because items cannot be empty.
Alright, I'll add some items. So in here,
when you're going to need to define circular
menu items, this first one is going to be a big
End Call button. So we never want to end that
call, we will call the director notifier leave
call and then pop out of this context. So go
back to the old screen. And then a second item
we'll have in here is check whether we are live or
not. If we are live at a button called end stream,
where we call the end stream function that we
haven't yet implemented. And if we are not live,
we will call start stream and the colors will
be orange for both of them. And this one will be
a video cam icon and then this one will
be a cancel icon. And then we also do a
little check here before we started to make sure
that there's at least one destination and where
we want to start the stream to. If not,
we'll throw an error called invalid URL.
Alright, so let's try again and go to the
director. And we should hopefully see a
nice little button in the bottom right.
There we go. Now if we click this button,
you'll see an end call and a start live stream.
So and the call will take us back to this screen
and go back into the director. Alright, so that
section is done. Now the next is this safe area
that we just left an empty container for now.
So that was on purpose, we're actually going
to turn this into a row. So for this one, we're
going to use another package that we added in,
called the pop up menu button. And we're
going to use it in conjunction to this
modal bottom sheet as well. So the pop
up menu button takes in the item builder,
where we'll need to return a list of pop up menu
items. We're gonna need to turn this list at the
end. And before we return them, we need to fill
it up with all the different things we need.
So this part is going to be where we're adding
the actual stream destinations. And everything
within here needs to be a pop up menu item and it
will have a child and the value. And the reason we
had that enumeration that we declared as because
we Want this value to be to be for YouTube. Now
the child will be a simple list tile. And just
like that, we have our first pop up menu item,
then we'll add a little divider in
between using the pop up menu divider.
And that's put in the wrong spot. There we go. And
I'll have a load divided between the next section
where we can copy paste the same thing.
Call this Twitch, made the streaming
platform twitch. And then copy this
a third time to add an other field.
Alright, so we have our pop up menu defined
here. But there's a couple more things we need
to add in. So the icon going to use a similar
icons to add. And there's some functions you
can implement like on canceled where all
we'll do is just print you have canceled
menu, then we have on selected. So if
you actually choose something, and this
is where this value comes in very handy, we can
create a switch case statement for this value.
If it's a stream platform, dot YouTube
we will do one thing. If it's
if it's Twitch, we will do something separate.
And then lastly, we will have a shape
of rounded rectangle border with border
radius of border radius circular of 16.
All right, there we go. So the next big thing
is when we actually picked one want to have a
little bottom sheet pop out. So for YouTube,
we will have a function called Show YouTube
bottom sheet, where we'll need to pass
the context and the director notifier.
Because we'll need to access that
function to add the published
destination. Alright, so
let's create this function.
We will do it up here. And before we implement
this, let's go over how to actually stream
something to YouTube. Sorry, go to YouTube, you're
ready to go live. And click this go live button.
And you will have this stream key and you'll
have a stream URL. And those are two things
you're going to need to do an RTMP push to YouTube
on Twitch to get a stream key as well. But but you
can go to stream that twitch.tv/ingests. And
it'll tell you what the actual URL you need.
So you take this URL at the beginning and then
add your stream key at the end. And using those
two values, you can actually RTMP push your
stream to both of the platforms. So I need to
input that here. Okay, text editing controller
with the stream URL, then copy that and have
a stream key. And for this return, we actually
wanted to be want to return a bottom sheet here.
And we get that from show modal bottom sheet.
So we have the context. And within the builder,
we actually need to build out this form.
And nothing too complicated about this one.
We just basically fill out a column with all
the things that we want to add. So first add a
little text, then some space between the next
thing, then a text field for our stream URL,
text field for our stream key. And then a nice
button at the bottom that says Add. And this
goes to our director notifier and does the Add
publish destination, we add a YouTube destination.
We take the stream URL, add a slash and add
the stream key to the end. And that's our
URL for the stream destination. So this guy I was
reading earlier had a different way to set up the
put stream. So they said do RTMP slash slash
Twitch ingest server slash app slash stream key.
And the way I found this Twitch ingest server
was going through OBS, but I have a feeling
this would work just fine. So maybe maybe
you want to make this your URL and make it
more clear to your users how to how this all
works. But yeah, the main point is that your
app actually goes gets a twitch so try these
out. And maybe this is actually simpler to use,
just guide people to this website and then they
could find it plus had a very similar function
for Twitch. So the way I had it was using this
old method with our TMP slash slash slash AP.
And then string key. Again, just going to
the direct and just sir might be easier.
So feel free to update this as necessary. Okay,
those two are implemented. Now it could show
Twitch bottom sheet, we have context and director
notifier. All there. Now when we click on this,
we should see these options pop up. Sorry,
we had this first pop up menu button.
And right after that pop up menu button, we're
going to loop through all of the destinations
and return some more pop up menu buttons, what
the actual streams. So number, the item builder
needs to be a list of things even though this is
just one thing the child will be stream button
with the director data and destination for that
specific one, or define what this stream button
is in a second, and then the same three functions
we have the odd cancelled, you have cancelled the
menu on selected, instead of adding a published
destination here, we will be removing a published
destination what that specific URL again, and
then very similar border. So last part of the UI,
we want to add the stream button. So this
will return a widget of stream button.
And we're going to pass it a stream destination,
we could set up a nice switch statement. Depending
on the platform. If it's YouTube, we want to
return a container with a child text that says
YouTube style it to be white, give it a little
bit of decoration. And then since it's YouTube,
we want to make it red. Give it a little
bit of padding a little bit of margin.
And there we go. So YouTube wants to find
we'll have a very similar thing for Twitch,
instead of red here we'll have purple,
instead of YouTube, we will have twitch
and the rest should be the same. And then lastly,
we have the other will make this color black.
Change this Twitch to other. Okay,
so finally the UI should be done.
Let's run it. So again, we have this
director Chowning tatis, let's join it.
And we'll see this nice plus icon at the top.
If we click this, we'll see a bunch of options,
YouTube, Twitch other let's click
YouTube will see this pop up
stream URL that's just put in for now
youtube.com Just as a test stream key, whatever.
We actually had some sort of overflow there. But
anyways, add that in and we should see YouTube
we can click on YouTube to remove it. Now
let's figure out what this is all about.
So we need to add this is scroll controlled, and
set this to true for our bottom sheets. And then
we won't have that overflow problem.
And we did on this one. All right.
Now in this case, we go to YouTube order flow.
Might want to add some sort of checks here.
But we just want to make sure it
all looks nice first. Go to twitch.
Add in there we have multiple things. Okay,
remove them and add them as necessary. So
UI is all there. So now the very very last
thing is we actually need to push this stream
to our streaming platforms. And we actually have
this all set up. So we have n stream and we have
start stream already and set up to go. And we
only have three functions to implement there.
There's an update stream and streaming
start stream update streaming. Remember,
we call this whenever the active users changed.
So that's already handled. So this is also called
whenever we need. So last thing is just just
implement them. Let's start with the empty
string because it's the easiest one. So we loop
through all the destinations. And remember to add
a publish destination, we do this add public
stream URL to mu do remove public stream URL.
So all we really need to do is loop through and
remove every single public stream URL, just like
that. And then we set the state to state copy with
is live false. And that's how you end the stream.
Now for the start stream. We need to create a
list of transcoding users. So if the active user
is empty, we should probably do some sort of error
checking. Find this case we're going to pretend we
don't like error checking and move to state Active
Users length equals one. So the best showcase what
we need to do with this transcoding is to look
at this this drawn out image. So transcoding
means we need to define the width and the height
of each user and where their location is within
that block. So here, when we only have one, we
have a use it as 1920 by 1080. And their index
is 00. For this one, we have two users, each
user will have the resolution of 960 by 1080.
And this one will start at 00. But
this one will start at 960, and zero.
And then so on for we're going to do it up
to eight users. By the way, if you prefer
reading through a blog, this will also be in the
description. So back to the better code. So this
is what that looks like. So like I said, if we
only have one user to start, this will be 00,
which will be 1920 by 1080. If we have two
users, first of all, start at 00 960. By 1087,
we'll start at 960 comma 09 60, by 1080, and so on
and so forth, up to eight users. Now then there's
this live transcoding variable we need, are we
passing passing those transcoding users that we
just defined, and set the total stream height
and width to 1920 by 1080. Then on the engine,
we set, live transcoding with the transcoding that
we just declared, that means we are now live with
the transcoding with these configurations.
And then similar thing as we did for
the end stream, we want to do for the start
stream where we go through every destination
and want to add publish stream URL. And the second
variable is whether transcoding is enabled. And
that is, so we set that to true. And then is live
also to true. Now last one update stream. So for
updating, we're not really changing. Whether we're
live or not, we're not changing or adding any
published stream URLs. Those are done
here, right when we do the Add or Remove.
So all we need to do is update the
transcoding whenever the users get added.
So copy paste all this paste on the update stream.
And that is it. That is the last line of code
for the fully functioning streamer application
that allows you to stream with multiple
people that you have control over
and allows you to stream to multiple platforms at
the same time. Now I understand that some of this
might have been a little bit complex. But this
is a complex application complex use case. But
I'm hoping that a lot of you, after looking at
the proper resources, were able to follow along
and see how a gore actually made this a lot
easier than it would be to make from scratch,
I honestly don't know where I would even
start trying to implement this without a guru.
So let's see this final product in action. We're
gonna run this app and I have a YouTube account.
That's not the official YouTube account. And the
nice thing about YouTube is it lets you see your
stream here before actually going live on like
Twitch and makes you go live instantly. I found
this out from experience. But we'll be able to run
and stream our stream to here and we'll see all
the changes update, it might not be as smooth here
because I'm running an emulator on a stream. And
then we'll be using two other devices to stream
into the actual streamer app as well. So this
user will be the director. So you could see this
all in action, we'll use a channel named Titus.
On join us director. Now we can assign the YouTube
stuff right away, and paste that in here. And then
copy paste the stream key in here as well. Now for
this one, we might want to hide it in this case,
especially if you're live streaming this app.
You don't want people to see this, of course.
But for now, we don't really mind, I'll
just change my stream key right after this.
So you won't be able to use it. So you have
added a destination. Now let's also run the
same application, the iPad that I have connected.
And let's open up a new instance of the terminal
and run a third instance on the iPhone that was
available here too. So the first device is there.
We'll call this user named Titus. I will see his
show up here. If you guys are part of the flutter
community, and you know me, you probably know my
good friend, Robert, that's also on YouTube. We'll
pretend like he's the other person in here. So
there we go. So let's say we bring this user in,
and what I'll do is mute them right away so the
two devices don't start echoing with each other.
Alright, well should be ready to push
the stream live. We click this button,
start live stream. And we see we have a connection
here. So one thing to remember this whole app,
everything we see here is running on a Gora.
So this will probably be relatively fast.
But when it starts going out to YouTube, and
there we go, we finally see it when I started
going out to YouTube is going to the CDN using
RTMP. So we'll have a little bit of a delay
Someone can bring this other user in. And
let's meet them here as well. And you can see
pop up here too. So our apps fully working, we're
gonna bring them in, we could take them out now,
and update just like it should. And there you
go. You see this layout updates, just how it's
supposed to as well. So you can add twitch and
all these other streams and stream to all of them.
And if you want to enable the stream right away
to both of them, whenever you start streaming
from the app, click this auto start and then the
Twitch will automatically start and then YouTube
will automatically start. So there we go. That's
the app I like to call streamer. Now if you'd like
to learn more about flutter development, or just
overall developer entertainment comm subscribe
to my youtube channel at Titus Petro. If you're
interested to learn more about a gore and how
all this video SDK in this real time engagement
works, go subscribe to their channel at agora
and over I really appreciate you watching until
the end of this video. This is definitely the
longest video I've ever made and probably the most
complex project that I've tried to explain with a
video. I'm hoping most of you are able to keep
up with it. If you have any questions make sure
to put them in the comments. I'll try to answer
them as much as I can. And lastly, I'd like to
thank Freako camp for giving me this opportunity
and hopefully I'll see around here some more